senator catherine cortez masto says she  is running for a second term  and i am excited to share with you that  i'm officially launching my campaign for  re-election  she made the announcement in a video on  social media this morning  cortez masto became the first latina to  ever serve in the senate when she was  elected in 2016.  she tells 8 news now there's simply more  work to do especially around coronavirus  relief  what more needs to be done and i think  that's important  for all of us to to really understand  that at a federal level  my goal here has always been to work on  behalf the people of nevada and make  sure that we're bringing that relief  across the state the former state  attorney general has no clear opponent  this early in the race which by the way  is not until november of 2022